do you think that the U.S provoked
Russia through its operations in Ukraine
I think what provoked Russia was our
failure to withdraw effectively from
Afghanistan and we were so feckless and
it was such that's not to criticize
anybody that was on the ground doing the
work that's not what I'm criticizing but
the the failure that was a debacle and I
think Putin looked at that I think when
they opened up the pilot Bureau archives
in like 50 years and they look at their
National Security Council notes they're
going to go like wow Putin saw that as
weakness in the United States and saw
that as a green light to go after we saw
it we saw it in Taiwan why did Russia go
into Ukraine
I have no idea I think I know I think
they want Sebastopol as a trade Port
when the Soviet Union broke up they took
it and they gave Black Sea access like
Mediterranean access to Ukraine they
want to keep Russia from becoming a
global economic hegemon but now he's
trying to take Sebastopol on the
freeways East uh 97 and 105 that go down
into there I watched the morning shows
you know where they had all the retired
generals the Barry McCaffrey and Admiral
stavaritus and all these guys who used
to watch that all the time right man and
you remember last year at this time
they're like key will fall in 72 hours
and then of course today they're like oh
the Freedom Fighters of Ukraine the
reason I bring this up is anybody that
predicts what's going to happen over
there I have no confidence I agree I
think everything we've been told from
everybody you know it's just even been
wrong about what what the directory of
the war is going to be do you think it
would be I think I think uh Russia
obviously has its interests with Ukraine
so it's not fair to completely blame the
U.S operations for provoking Russia
Russia wanted like like he was saying
Sebastopol Crimea sure Don bass region
regardless of what the U.S was doing
what ultimately happens is I think
Vladimir Putin laments the fact that
they lost Ukraine with the fall of the
Soviet Union they want access they have
operations in Crimea and then both the
U.S and Russia aren't engaged are
engaged in influence operations in
Ukraine in an attempt to win the favor
of Ukrainian people but it seemed like
for the most part majority of the
country was moving towards NATO and the
EU even when I went there that's what I
saw the people in in Kiev were like we
want access to Europe Europe was wealth
for these people they said if we get
schengen's own if Ukraine becomes a part
of the Schengen Zone and we can freely
travel and work our standard of living
is going to Skyrocket our wealth will
Skyrocket Russia's offer with the
Federal Trade union was not that
appealing to them of course you get the
ousting of yanakovich U.S involvement to
whatever degree you've got Joe Biden
barisma energy operations competing with
Russia both the U.S NATO Russia have
heavy interests Russia moved in because
the U.S was winning the conflict there
was a cold war with Ukraine before there
was a hot War Russia turned it hot
because the U.S was winning it well the
annexed Crimea which was potentially
could have went hot but they didn't they
just let it happen and then because of
that influence the the annexation of
Crimea was the line between cold and hot
they brought in military into the region
there was not a lot of fighting but they
took that land then it went hot in the
donbass region Donald Trump gets elected
everything kind of simmers a little bit
down do you think if we would have
reacted differently to this seizure of
Crimea in 2014
that this situation would be different
uh in what way what do you mean because
Obama we didn't do we didn't do Jack we
let him take and yeah and you know maybe
we were too concerned about something I
don't know the U.S should have declared
a no-fly zone well so there's a couple
ways I look at this first my my
principal morals are if they cannot
justify to me and the American people
why we should be spending money and
being involved in Ukraine it shouldn't
happen in the first place strategically
Obama should have declared a no-fly zone
instantly over the donbass region and
Ukraine which ukrainians would have
supported outright and that would have
prevented Russia from aggressing in the
first place because that would be a
direct Act of war against the United
States when it came to their build up on
the border a year a year ago before The
Invasion I and many other people were
like the U.S strategically should have
declared a no-fly zone before Russia
invaded because then Russians Russia's
move would have been active aggression
against the U.S putting them in a very
difficult position instead we have a
Biden who sits on his hands and does
nothing and the military apparatus
around him Russia moves in and now our
hands are tied now we're sinking money
into a toilet and it's just I like you
were saying what more money than
Afghanistan yeah so I saw 20 years of
Afghanistan in 20 years of Vietnam even
crystal ball was talking about this it
is a strategic nightmare so this is a
component of why I'm like we should not
be in this conflict we should have
nothing to do with it we have I mean Ian
we surrender Afghanistan it's a it's a
disaster you mentioned Putin sees this
and he's like wow now's my opportunity
it has been just look man you know
everybody knows I've been playing poker
recently you get a bad hand you fold if
you don't and and the most important
lesson can learn is if you're if if
you're the eighth best player in the
world and you're at a table with the
seven other best players in the world
you're the sucker get out the US should
have seen everything that was going on
and been like you know we're really bad
at this and we're gonna lose cut your
losses leave we shouldn't be involved
Chris I want to ask you about
um so I understand that the arguments
that people make for helping out in
Ukraine frequent currently there's
something along the lines of well you
know if you don't stop Putin he's going
to keep going and he's going to take
he's going to try to to bring back the
Soviet Union Etc and those arguments to
me are not compelling at all and that's
just because NATO what's wrong with
waiting
to for NATO to actually get involved
until there's an actual threat to a NATO
country there was a reason why Ukraine
is not in NATO now and this is literally
it if I understand correctly NATO didn't
want Ukraine because they didn't want to
directly have a conflict with Russia and
that's what we're getting at right now
if we if we continue to support Ukraine
at some point there's going to be dead
NATO soldiers and then there's going to
be people talking about Article Five and
and and I don't see the off ramp
at all right now I don't see how we
avoid that because we keep we keep
committing to indefinite uh support
until the you know until Russia's beaten
and we and the realistic perspective is
Russia is only going to be beaten if
they choose to be because they do have
nuclear weapons so I don't see where the
off ramp is
with with with us supporting Ukraine the
way that we are what what are your
thoughts on um a NATO president Trump is
right what can't freeload anymore good
on NATO good on NATO for all those years
after World War II where we pay we
bankrolled their security cold War's
been over what 30 years
some say it never ended just switch to
China yeah oh yeah good point oh that's
a good one oh we could go someplace on
that one yep talking about the military
industrial complex uh so
the polls when I went over there uh I
was over there a couple yeah six eight
weeks after the war started the polls
went to this University right and uh
gave a lecture to some International
Affairs class it was interesting they
liter the leadership of the University
got a sidebar with me and said should we
evacuate and set up an alternate
University I said why they're like
because we think we're gonna get a
nuclear weapon strikes coming in they
were petrified now your point about uh
you know do you think Putin
you think Putin would make a move on uh
on a NATO country I don't and that's why
I think that's why we shouldn't that's
existential exactly and that's why I
think that as as harsh as this is going
to sound to a lot of people we should
keep our nose out of Ukraine because I
don't see
Putin actually making an attack on a
NATO country because that isn't a that's
that that just I don't see any benefit
for for Putin to do that it's it to
actually
try to engage in a war with NATO if
there's a lack of NATO Unity then I
could see him invading Estonia or Latvia
and then posing the question to the
American public and Europeans are you
guys really willing to fight and die for
Estonia because that's what a lot of
people in the United States would be
asking and if you guys ask me that I I
don't know I would respond do you think
American soldiers should die in Estonia
if Russia invades that's the question
you just nailed it I know you that's in
Germany I know yeah so you know I don't
know if the American public is ready to
answer that question if Russia was
willing to take it there Chris what do
you
good oh no you guys go ahead I I hear
the secretary yeah I would not die for
the Estonian people at the moment thank
you I love you people I love you and I'm
here for you in my own way I think he's
not shooting people for you uh but I
think Putin's D disincentivize of of
attacking NATO countries because he
needs turkey he does he does it let's be
clear he does not have the ass right now
like there's this there is this great
statement that I heard when we were uh
losing in Iraq uh the second or third
time I can't remember what time it was
uh great Powers should never fight small
Wars because one of two things happens
one is you they win and they look like a
complete bully and everybody gangs up
against him or two you they don't win
and you show your blood in the water
you're feckless everybody goes wow
that's a paper tiger I don't think
Russia Russia they do not have the
combat capability right now to do
anything I mean so why why God damn
nukes though oh come so
right so I'm all
I'm all about Strategic Defense
Initiative you know Star Wars like I we
were talking technology earlier dude I
think we have the ability to put that
you know we were talking earlier about
putting the bubble around I think we can
do that so yeah Defense Initiative just
like Star Wars remember everybody made
fun of Reagan like this guy's a complete
lunatic the problem with defensive
bubbles is things that come straight
down uh pierce the bubble or or a better
chance to pierce the bubble like
Hypersonic straight down but they're
right the real issue is Russia
probably as invested in cyber warfare
more than anything else well information
operations too but if they're hot farms
and everything yes but I think the
bigger issue is Russia probably has the
capability of blowing up an oil refinery
in a minute
it's it's the the cyber security is not
impossible you can it's very easy to
attack it's extremely difficult to
defend you have so many attack vectors
throughout the country
you you won't even it's impossible to to
shore up defenses because you don't know
which of the tens of thousands of
industrial plants to protect and you can
start by trying to protect all of them
update every single one but even when
you do eventually someone will find a
new exploit the military the the the
Russians will every single day be trying
to find a way to break through and they
will find it and then they can do who
knows what what do you think ethically
about a general Armistice with uh the
Russian army like in eastern Ukraine
because what I think is happening is
they want that Black Sea port they want
to be able to ship into the
Mediterranean and sell steel to the
world the United States everybody
everybody and uh that means an alliance
with turkey which means an alliance with
NATO so the the end goal seems very
positive for everyone involved if except
for the fact that the ukrainians would
have to seed the Eastern territory the
Don bass or the southern donbass but do
you think that that's a reasonable
de-escalation tactic you're triggering
me and this is where the American
hypocrisy bothers me that there's this
idea that somehow we can dictate terms
the ukrainians get to decide and the
Russians get to decide we can stop
giving them money and you know what if
we stop giving them money and we stop
giving them stuff they're not going to
stop fighting and it's going to go old
school so that's that's not funny when
they get flattened and there's no one
left to fight you
ukrainians have shown that they the
biggest change I saw from when you were
over there right it used to be about 50
50 split 50 were like let's go Rush away
50 let's go to the E let's go to the
West leaning Western but dude last time
over there man the hatred I'm sure it's
like 90 yeah the donbis and all that
they're obviously that that's the trade
space we all know that but my point is
we're not going to get to decide that
the ukrainians get to decide then how do
Wars win or how do Wars end exhaustion
and those two countries don't seem to be
exhausted yet so yeah but Ukraine is
look Russia's got its problems
militaristically but Ukraine's only able
to do anything because of NATO support
if we were not providing them with
weapons and intelligence they would have
been flattened in a week
Russia or even Russia I totally disagree
the way that and that's part of my book
actually is we talked about how we
should need to fight differently when
the Russians came down from the north to
try to capture Keith and what did you
have you had like Babushka women out
there you know slapping plastic
explosives on freaking uh you know
Russian tanks you had little hunter
killer teams with their pickup truck and
you know uh and anti-tank guns and stuff
so that that's my point is they're
absolutely capable of Defending
themselves even if we pulled everything
out they'd get a lot worse that's a
great argument for us to pull everything
out and back off and be and because if
that's the case then I see no reason for
us to be why why it's not you know what
are we gaining from the one we get why
yeah I want to ask you that like why
would we bail why would we pull out when
we can fix the Russian war machine in a
interminable War thanks for watching
this clip from from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time